so let's start with the basics what is
sugar sugar is a natural ingredient that
has always been part of our diet or
sugars are carbohydrates that are found
naturally in most foods that provide
energy for our body however nowadays
sugars are also added to a lot of foods
to enhance their taste texture and
flavors these are also known as free
sugars if you carefully read the food
label most of the processed foods we
consume contains sugar and no companies
will not just list it down as sugar bar
rather hide behind scientific names such
as sucrose fructose glucose molasses
invert sugar or corn syrup there are now
estimated to be around 60 different
names for these free sugars hence it is
very important for you to read it the
food labels and know how to identify
sugar you might be thinking I don't eat
that much sugar well the truth is you
might be consuming sugar without even
realizing it so here are top five signs
you might just be addicted to sugar the
first sign is you eat sugary foods past
the point you intended imagine this
scenario I really want to treat myself
to that nice slice of cake oh gosh it
tastes so good maybe I shouldn't do you
know what maybe just one more slice oh
it's so good before you know it you have
treated yourself to five slices and you
still want more you feel extremely
guilty and regretful immediately
afterward second sign you crave simple
carbs sugar addiction isn't just about
sweets all cops turn into sugar in our
body so even if you don't have a sweet
tooth but if you crave simple carbs such
as pretzels biscuits pastries pasta or
even white bread then what if you're
really craving is sugar hence even if
you feel full and satisfied from a
really healthy meal you still want to
snack on simple carbs the
sign you crave meat or salty foods you
might be wondering what that has nothing
to do with sugar it's important to know
that a healthy body always strives
towards balance so if you find your body
craving for a lot of meat or salty foods
this may be a sign that your body is
seeking balance due to the large sugar
intake the next sign is you eat yourself
sick on sugary foods have you ever eaten
so many cookies that you experience one
or more of these symptoms headaches gas
bloating or sleepiness if so those are
symptoms of a sugar hangover you do this
to yourself a few times a week if not
every day and you feel extremely crappy
afterwards to you the short-term
pleasure of eating that cakes chocolates
or sweets are worth the unpleasant
after-effects the final sign is you're
going through withdrawal all you have
told yourself I'm going to quit sugar
and that's exactly what you did but
before you know it you experience in
mediate withdrawal symptoms such as
headaches fatigue low energy and even
mood swings the next thing you're back
snacking on sugary foods just to make
you feel better if you say yes to four
out of five of these signs you might
just be addicted to sugar let's look at
a difference between natural sugars and
added sugars natural sugars are present
in fruits such as fruits vegetables and
also milk they are part of the whole
food and contain protein or fiber on the
other hand added sugar also known as
free sugars as sweeteners that do not
occur naturally in a whole food but
rather they're intentionally added by
manufacturers to enhance the taste and
texture of a product added sugars are
empty calories and contain no nutrients
whatsoever they do more harm than good
to your body it's important to know that
our body does not distinguish between
the different types of sugar and
breaks them down in exactly the same way
whether its natural or added say that
however foods containing natural sugars
like fruits have beneficial nutrients
such as fiber which will aid your
digestion and keeps you full so eating a
piece of fruit will not cause your blood
sugar level to spike in comparison to
drinking a can of soda overall you will
still need to control the total amount
of sugar whether its natural or added
because excess amount of sugar in your
liver can lead to health problems like
this video and share this video with a
friend whom you think might have an
addiction with sugar do also check out
more videos right here which will help
you through your fitness journey don't
forget to subscribe to my youtube
channel for a lot more new videos every
Monday and Thursday and hit the
notification button so that you will get
notified every time I upload a new video
all the best